foreign
[Music]
Disney now dares to tackle its greatest
classic ever an evil stepmother a
poisonous apple and a glass coffin the
talk is of course of the world famous
fairy tale character Snow White back in
1937 Walt Disney recognized the story's
potential and created Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs the very first
feature-length animated film ever made a
remake is planned for 2024 and in this
video we reveal all the latest details
about the plot cast and production of
the live-action Disney movie so stay
tuned
in the case of Snow White we are talking
about a typical remake so we can largely
expect the same well-known story
Princess Snow White ends up in the
forest because of her envious stepmother
finds shelter among the seven dwarfs and
continues to be confronted with the
Queen's attempts to murder her most of
us will have come to know and love the
story but the Remake is supposed to
include a couple of changes notably in
the details apparently Disney is
adopting a completely new approach to
the presentation of the seven dwarfs in
order to avoid a cliched realization
like in the old film during Disney's d23
event there were already hints of a
contemporary working of the story this
is meant to appeal to a progressive
audience the current movie title already
points this out it's just Snow White
without any mention of the seven dwarfs
like the original Game of Thrones star
Peter Dinklage in particular may have
had a certain influence in this Regard
in 2022 he was upset that the story of
the Seven Dwarfs was really behind the
times Dinklage who himself has a common
form of dwarfism clearly felt
discriminated against by the Remake
plans however he was promptly assured by
Disney that they wanted to avoid the
stereotypes of the original as much as
possible currently First Impressions
from the set are doing the rounds they
show a double of the protagonist and her
seven companions a group of men and
women with different skin colors and
body sizes a further change is the
origin of the main character skin as
white as snow lips as red as blood and
hair is black as ebony that's how the
brothers Grim chose to describe Snow
White in their fairy tale and that's
also how she was presented in the
animated film however leading actress
Rachel zegler does not quite match this
image for the US American has Colombian
Origins actually the fairy tale is very
popular in Latin American countries in
particular which is why Disney must have
had a somewhat easier time deciding on
this rather atypical casting yet again
there was a lot of criticism on the web
to which zegler answered dryly by saying
that people would first have to be
convinced of the new Latina princess's
merits another notable difference from
the original is the introduction of a
new character will play Snow White's
love interest this character named
Jonathan is a brand new character not
known from the animated film so there
will likely be no Prince and we suspect
that even the matter of being kissed
awake by a stranger will probably play
out a bit differently than we know from
the original Disney movie we can't wait
to hear what other changes will be made
in the remake and how much of the
original story will be kept in the end
although the cast is still quite small
it is already made up of well-known
actors as already mentioned the lead
role of Snow White will be played by
Rachel zegler who is impressive in the
Spielberg remake of West Side Story will
also star in the new Hunger Games movie
The Evil Queen will be played by Wonder
Woman star Gal Gadot while the part of
the new character Jonathan will be
assumed by Broadway actor Andrew bernap
onto kabia who appeared in movies such
as Hobbes and Shaw and murder on the
Orient Express will play the Huntsman
a remake of Snow White has been in the
works for quite some time as early as
2016 variety published an early report
on a new Disney film for which The
Amazing Spider-Man director Mark Webb
ended up being signed on he'll be joined
by Greta Gerwig and Aaron Cresta Wilson
as screenwriters Gerwig in particular is
currently on everyone's lips thanks to
her Barbie film shooting began in March
2022 and was concluded four months later
in July the movie is currently slated
for a March 22nd 2024 release but at
first trailer is currently still
unavailable
we hope you enjoyed our little preview
of Snow White let us know in the
comments how you feel about the new
approach to the Remake and give the
video a thumbs up if you liked our
preview thanks for watching and see you
soon
[Music]
foreign